here is the classic New Yorker taking
umbrage at the fact that some guy was
tearing down posters of the missing
hostages who were taken by Hamas I'm
telling
you je he not Jewish I don't know if he
is or not doesn't matter This Is Us New
York City you don't right to touch there
a free country you can wave your
Palestine flag and say death to the Jews
or America whenever you want but we can
put a
okay then don't rip that down you are
doing something you're offending
us yeah you are when you throw that on
the floor you're litter in the city in a
minute I'm going to litter the floor
with you so move the on do you have
proof they're not kidna no so shut
the I know that's what you
want maybe it's because I'm a New Yorker
myself but this kind of reaction I love
it